Seattle, Washington: the Emerald City has roots in nature...
...and high tech is pushing it to grow Silicon branches.
Enter Michael Mattmiller:...
...ex-Microsoft now Seattle's chief technology officer.
Before dawn, he's online,...
...pushing his digital initiatives.
So, this is our dashboard, where the public can come to get information on how their government's performing.
Performance Seattle is his centerpiece.
Just launched in February, open public data tells the state of the city.
So, the public gets a very real-time view of what's happening.
How is the city doing at reducing crime, car prowls?
How are we doing at responding timely to fire 911 calls?
Mattmiller is one of a growing number of CTOs across the US...
...from New York to Los Angeles and Washington, DC.
Mattmiller believes that technology is key to reshaping the future of Seattle...
...and improving the lives of its citizens.